while they distract you with Trump China
has been unifying our enemies with China
convincing yet another giant country to
ditch the US dollar and this is gonna
affect everyone from the past 80 years
America has had the privilege of the
dollar being the global Reserve currency
for almost 80 years almost all
International Trade has been based on
the dollar which has given America an
insane amount of power to strong arm
every other country and climb to the top
it allows the US to print as much money
as they want while the rest of the world
has to Bear the brunt of their inflation
it allows the US to crush whatever
country it wants without going to war
simply by imposing sanctions on them
Venezuela Iran these countries have
taken a beating without ever having to
launch an expensive Invasion and all of
this is only possible because of the
dollar
and China hates this they want out of
this dollar dominated world and now
they've gotten another massive country
on their side Brazil and this is huge
China has been Brazil's biggest trading
partner since 2009. the two countries
Import and Export hundreds of billions
of dollars worth of Commodities between
each other every year and for decades
the dollar was the only way they could
trade at all but just this week in an
announcement no one saw coming Brazil
and China officially agreed to ditch the
dollar for good and to start to trade
with each other in their own currencies
this move has put Brazil and China's
trade beyond the reach of America's
grubby little fingers but it's not just
Brazil China has been successfully
getting a slew of other countries to
gradually join the anti-dullar
anti-america movements which means soon
we can live in a world where the US is
not on top and the West is pathetically
in the Nile of this
stay dangerous and let's get into it
[Music]
and quick side note we're starting to
make a lot more videos to cover stuff
like this faster for you guys which
means we're gonna have a lot more
sponsor spots available and I was
thinking about it and I thought if we're
going to be promoting more Brands we
might as well promote your Brands being
that a lot of entrepreneurs watch this
channel so if you run a company or you
manage the marketing spend of a company
and you want to be featured in one of
our responsible spots send us an email
at business jtrend.io that's business
jtrend.io in the description below now
back to the video
China and Brazil have been Buddy buddies
back in 2009 China overtook the us as
Brazil's top trading partner today
Brazil is the largest recipient of
Chinese investment in Latin America and
since 2009 China and Brazil's economic
ties have only gotten stronger but
there's always been an annoying third
wheel the US dollar see no matter how
much China and Brazil traded it all had
to be done in dollars which meant they
had to use Western systems like Swift
that could be cut off if their
currencies were devalued against the
dollar they would be hit with massive
price inflation and in the end America's
economy would always benefit from
whatever transactions they made no
matter how badly they wanted to be
Independence but now they're not only
ditching the dollar but they're also
ditching the Swift payment system a real
based Chinese bank will be connected to
China's cross-border interbank payment
system or kips on alternative to Swift
to support trade settlements between
China and Brazil and China's RMB so now
America will have zero control over how
the two countries trade with each other
it's the first time in 80 years that two
countries this big have openly gone up
against America and the dollar and
Brazil knows that by ditching a dollar
they are now making themselves big
enemies in the eyes of the us but they
don't care probably because they see how
the strike that America is with all of
America's drama and its crumbling
economy and here's the thing China and
Brazil aren't the only ones getting out
of the US dollar but the share of US
dollar reserves held by central banks
fell by 59 its lowest level in 25 years
during just the fourth quarter of 2020
alone and these are the other countries
that are jumping on the bandwagon
[Music]
the most obvious person who wants to
move away from the dollar right now is
Putin Russia has been slapped with
sanctions after sanctions so they have
had to move away from the dollar fast
and the currency Putin chose is the
Chinese yuan in 2022 trade between China
and Russia hit a record 190 billion
dollars that's more than qatar's entire
GDP or almost as much as Qatar spent on
the FIFA World Cup and most of that has
been done in currencies other than the
dollar the dollar share of Russia's
exports has been shrinking while the
Chinese you want to share has been
exploding but not only that the Chinese
Yuan has basically become Russia's new
Reserve currency energy experts are
increasingly getting paid in Yuan
Russia's Sovereign wealth fund a war
Chester support government spending
burden by Battlefield costs in Ukraine
is using the Chinese currency to store
its oral riches rushing companies have
borrowed a new one also known as RMB and
even householders dashing Savings in it
but that's not what the cooperation ends
China has become a major buyer of
Russian oil that is shown by the West
while Russia has grown more dependent on
China for semiconductors and other
technology in recent weeks the Yuan
Ruble was often the most traded currency
pair on the Moscow exchange based on
daily volume in fact the U1 is so
popular in Russia right now that average
everyday Russians are even opening
savings accounts in the Yuan to keep
their money safe from devaluation and
then there's the Middle East
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the Middle East the area of the world
has gone more than their fair share of
good old democracy I wonder why they
would want to move away from the dollar
and China has been instigating it Iran
and Saudi Arabia have always hated each
other the two countries have been on the
verge of war with each other for decades
but suddenly the two decide to settle
their differences and re-establish
diplomatic relations this was a huge
development and guess who was there to
mediate the deal China and definitely
not America but that's not where it ends
because thanks to their Newfound
diplomatic relations two of the middle
east's biggest oil producers are gonna
owe China a huge favor things like this
don't come for free now do they which
could be why Saudi Arabia is also
considering accepting Yuan instead of
dollars but the oil is sells to China if
that happens there's a good chance of it
triggering a domino effect where a bunch
of other countries all around the world
will want to pay for oil in their own
currencies too instead of the dollar
which would destroy one of the main
things that has been keeping the Dollar
on the top the petrol dollar the fact
that oil is only sold in dollars thanks
to Saudi Arabia and now even India is
joining in on the party
[Music]
India has historically been Rivals with
China mostly thanks to the two countries
sharing a 2 100 mile long border that
they constantly fight over the Border
disputes regularly end up in armed
confrontation between Chinese and Indian
soldiers which has made things between
the two governments pretty tense but now
even India is following China's lead by
announcing its plans to switch all
future International Trade to rupees
instead of dollars India's new foreign
trade policy to be adopted from April
1st will take steps to support
International Trade using the Ruby's
currency and India has even agreed to
bypass American sanctions by training
directly with Russia using rupees and
rubles India Iran Saudi Arabia all of
these volatile countries that could
never overcome the differences with each
other are now all moving away from the
dollar at the same time and this is no
coincidence now this is a formalized
coordinated effort to come together to
topple the dollar once and for all
foreign
this is bricks a coalition of countries
between Brazil Russia India China and
South Africa and it was just revealed by
a top Russian official that all of this
was all according to plan quote the
transition to settlements and National
currencies as the first step The Next
Step this one is important is to provide
the circulation of additional or any
other form of a fundamentally new
currency in the nearest Future in that
first up the transition to settlements
and National currencies is exactly what
we're seeing right now from Russia
Brazil and India and step number two the
creation of a fundamentally new currency
is already in the works the top Russian
official also said that the brics
alliance is working on creating its
currency and is scheduled to present
ideas on the matter at the
organization's forthcoming Summit in
South Africa in August this year August
22-24 that is the date where the world
may never be the same again that as the
day that might officially Mark the end
of the dollar while joining us now as
professor John qualch from the Miami
Herbert business school at the
University of Miami me so the brics
Nations aren't a formal trade Bloc so if
they do in fact create this new currency
how will It ultimately be used so I
think what we'd find is that would
initially be used in uh very large
transactions that are government uh
style transactions between uh two or
more of the countries involved you know
just to give a little bit of background
here it is the case that the U.S dollar
has a rule that is outsized relative to
the 24 of world GDP that the U.S
commands so the U.S dollar is involved
in almost 90 percent of all
International Trade settlements and
around about 60 percent of foreign
currency reserves around the world held
by central banks are held in U.S dollars
So the brics Nations combined their GDP
is around about 25 percent of world GDP
vis-a-vis the U.S now at 24 and so it's
not surprising that these nations
collectively are saying hey wait a
minute why should our
macroeconomic policies and exchange
rates uh uh be at the mercy of U.S
dollar uh Federal Reserve decision
making but no one in the west wants to
believe it so many reporters and
academics out there are saying that this
is impossible but they're never going to
topple the dollar it's too hard but they
also thought that Rome could never fall
even when it was on the brink of
collapsing they also thought the British
pound would never fall even as Brynn was
being dethroned as the global superpower
and the same with the Dutch before it
but all of them every single empire fell
and no one believed it until it happened
so breakdown what this would mean if
this currency does come to fruition how
is it going to impact the strength of
the US dollar and what does it mean for
the average person out there well a good
analogy Natasha would be the euro uh
which of course has now been around for
uh uh three plus decades uh and when the
Euro came in it was you know not
regarded as that strong an opponent to
the dollar uh but the fact is that the
European nations have of course uh used
the euro to facilitate all of their
intra-european trade and some trade
beyond that as well as now carried out
in Euros so what I think you would see
here if there is such a bricks type
Association which I think by the way
would be very difficult to pull off
because there is no uh trade block as
you said that involves these five
nations but if there were such a
currency as I said it would primarily be
used initially for uh intra trade among
the five nations uh before then being
potentially expanded out to to other
nations the Chinese have of course long
aspired to develop a digital Yuan as an
alternative trading currency they
haven't made a tremendous amount of
progress and so I think this partnership
is reflective of that and the Chinese
are trying to use the bricks Association
as a way to further push the Yuan though
they're saying it doesn't matter if it's
a digital rupee a digital Yuan a digital
Ruble but in actuality I think we all
know that it would likely be a digital
Yuan or at least be heavily based on a
digital Yuan if it were to come into
existence
if you want to stay on top of what
happens at the next brics meeting or if
you want to be the first to hear about
any new developments in the story hit
that subscribe button and if you don't
know the story already you can learn
exactly how the US dollar came to
dominance in the first place in a free
video by clicking the square on the
screen they don't teach this stuff
anywhere else and if you enjoyed these
videos you are gonna love this one click
the square on the screen to watch now
[Music]